Here’s a question for the men who are watching.
Suppose you’re walking down the street,
and you see a beautiful woman.
What do you do?
Some of you are thinking, “Well, I’d ask for her number,
or try out my awesome new pick-up line”:
“Yo baby, how you like your eggs in the
morning, scrambled or fertilized?”
But what if you’re already married?
What do you do then?
Do you still ask for her number or use a lame
pick-up line?
“All right, here I am.
What are your other two wishes?”
If so, then you’re a total dirtbag . . . unless
you believe in the Quran,
which allows men to have up to four wives.
In that case, you could already be married
and still approach a woman as a second,
or third, or fourth wife.
So you could ask her for her number or try
out an Islamic pick-up line:
“Are you sure you’re not the prophet?
Because you robbed by heart.”
“Yo girl, you wanna share my prayer rug?”
“Girl I know you’re a Muslim, because
your body is-slamin.”
“Are you sure you’re not the Shaytan?
Because you fell from Jannah.”
“Yo girl, I know I’m only allowed to marry
four.
But you’re a ten.”
“I like your burqa.
I’m wondering if I could talk you out of
it.”
“Girl, I need to break my fast.
Can I have a date?”
“Are you sure you’re not the Black Stone?
Because I just wanna give you a big slobbery
kiss.”
But suppose you’re a Muslim, and you’ve
already massively exceeded the four-wife limit.
Suppose you already have nine or eleven wives,
not to mention multiple sex-slaves.
You’re walking down the street, and you
see a beautiful woman.
What do you do?
Fortunately for us, the Prophet of Islam has
the answer.
He always does, doesn’t he?
Sahih Muslim 3407:
It was narrated from Jabir that the Messenger
of Allah saw a woman,
then he came to his wife Zainab who was tanning
a leather, and fulfilled his desire,
then he went out to his Companions and said:
“A woman comes in the form of a devil and goes in the form of a devil.
If one of you sees a woman, let him go to his wife,
for that will repel what he feels in his heart.”
Now, what does Muhammad mean when he says
that having sex with his wife will repel
what he feels in his heart?
I think it’s obvious, but he elaborates
in Sahih Muslim 3409:
Jabir said: “I heard the prophet say: ‘If
one of you likes a woman and feels attracted
to her, let him go to his wife and have intercourse
with her, for that will repel what is in his heart.’”
So Muhammad saw a woman, and he was attracted
to her . . . sexually.
So he went to Zaynab’s house.
She was busy working, but Muhammad made her
stop what she was doing
so that he could have sex with her.
Then he went and told his followers that a
woman comes in the form of a devil
and goes in the form of a devil, and that if a man
sees a woman and is attracted to her,
he should run home and have sex with his wife,
because that will help alleviate his sexual desire.
All right, there’s a lot to think about
here.
Let me share my thoughts.
First, take a look at the chapter heading
for these hadiths:
Recommendation to the One Who Sees a Woman
and Is Attracted to Her,
to Go to His Wife or Slave Woman
and Have Intercourse with Her.
Again, this is about Muhammad, history’s
greatest moral example, being sexually aroused
by a woman and then running to Zaynab to,
quote, fulfill his desire.
Notice that a man can run home either to his
wife or to his slave girl.
Yes, Islam allows men to have sex slaves.
“But David, I thought that Islam abolished
slavery!”
Well, Islam did abolish slavery in one particular
area: Fantasy Land.
Here on Planet Reality, Muhammad and his followers
bought, owned, sold, and traded slaves,
and they had sex with them.
Second, how much self-control and will power
did the prophet of Islam have
if he couldn’t see a woman walking down the street
without running back to Zaynab’s house and saying,
“Stop what you’re doing.
There’s an emergency . . . in my thaub.
I need you to get into the bedroom, because I can’t
stop thinking about this sexy woman I just saw”?
To be fair, I think that if you don’t have
much self-control or will power,
and you become sexually aroused while running
some errands, you should go to your wife
instead of sitting around obsessing over
the woman you saw.
But think about this.
How many women do you walk by every day?
Probably a lot.
Do you have to run home every time you see
a woman?
And keep in mind, Muhammad saw a woman in
seventh-century Medina.
She would have been dressed pretty conservatively.
But Muhammad still couldn’t control himself.
This means, of course, that you and I and
pretty much everyone we know
have far, far more self-control—sexual self-control—
than the greatest man who ever lived.
Third, on this particular occasion, notice
which house Muhammad went to.
He went to Zaynab to “fulfill his desire.”
Who was Zaynab?
Zaynab was the former wife of Muhammad’s
adopted son Zayd.
One day when Muhammad went to visit his adopted son
Zayd, he was greeted by Zayd's wife Zaynab,
who was wearing very little clothing.
What happened next?
We read in the History of at-Tabari, Volume
8, page 2:
She jumped up in haste and excited the admiration
of the Messenger of God,
so that he turned away murmuring something
that could scarcely be understood.
However, he did say overtly: “Glory be to
God the Almighty!
Glory be to God, who causes hearts to turn.”
What do you think the narrator means when
he says that Zaynab “exited the admiration”
of Muhammad?
Long story short, Muhammad’s adopted son
Zayd heard that his adopted father/prophet
was lusting after his wife, so he divorced
her so that Muhammad could have her.
People complained about Muhammad marrying
the wife of his own adopted son,
so Muhammad abolished adoption in Islam.
What a prophet!
Putting all of this together, Muhammad saw
a woman walking down the street,
and he started lusting after her, so he ran to the
house of Zaynab,
a woman he married after breaking up her marriage
by lusting after her.
Wow!
No wonder Allah says in Surah 33, verse 21
of the Quran that Muhammad
is a wonderful pattern of conduct.
He sure sounds like one.
Fourth, when Muhammad saw this woman walking
down the street,
and he had to run to Zaynab for some relief,
he already had somewhere between
nine and eleven wives, not counting his sex-slaves.
And Muslim sources report that he would have
sex with all of his wives in one day.
Sahih al-Bukhari 5068:
Narrated Anas: The Prophet used to go round
(have sexual relations with)
all his wives in one night,
and he had nine wives.
Sahih al-Bukhari 5215:
Narrated Anas bin Malik: The Prophet used
to pass by (have sexual relation with)
all his wives in one night, and at that time
he had nine wives.
Side note: Check out the chapter heading.
“Whoever had sexual intercourse with all
his wives and then took one bath only.”
Yes, history’s greatest man would have sex
with nine women but would only take one bath.
Can you imagine what he would smell like when he
was climbing on top of poor wife number nine?
This is Allah’s pattern of conduct.
Sahih al-Bukhari 268:
Narrated Qatada: Anas bin Malik said, “The
Prophet used to visit all his wives in a round,
during the day and night and they were eleven
in number.”
I asked Anas, “Had the Prophet the strength
for it?”
Anas replied, “We used to say that the Prophet
was given the strength of thirty (men).”
And Sa’id said on the authority of Qatada
that Anas had told him about nine wives only
(not eleven).
Muhammad was having so much sex that his followers
were bragging that he had the sexual strength
of thirty men.
And keep in mind, we’re ignoring the sex
he had with his slave-girls.
And yet, despite being the most oversexed
man in the world,
he couldn’t see a woman walking down the street
without going into a sexual frenzy
and running to one of his wives.
If someone were to make an accurate film about
the life of Muhammad,
it would be on a porn site.
Fifth, in Islam, women are required to cover
themselves.
There’s some dispute as to whether they
can leave their faces uncovered or they have
to cover their faces as well, but think about
why they need to be covered.
Who founded this religion?
A man who would lose his mind when he saw
a woman walking down the street.
So I ask the Muslim women who are watching:
What’s the real reason you cover yourselves?
The real reason you cover yourselves is that
your prophet couldn’t control himself
around women, so he demanded that
women cover themselves.
Muslim women have been covering themselves
for fourteen centuries
because their religion was founded
by history’s greatest horndog.
Sixth, to you Christians who are watching,
can you even imagine reading something like this
about Jesus, or about Peter, or about
John, or about Paul?
Can you even imagine having to read about
Jesus seeing a woman and then having to run
to have sex with another woman, and then saying
that women are devils?
We don’t have to deal with this, because
the key figures in our religion were men of integrity,
men of honor, men of self-control—not
the epic pervert who stands at the center of Islam.
Thank God we don’t have to follow Muhammad.
So, those were my thoughts when I read Sahih
Muslim 3407.
But over the years, I’ve learned one thing
from the comments section:
Other people notice things that I don’t.
So in the comments, please share any additional
insights you’ve drawn
from the hadith we started with.
As an added bonus, the Apostate Prophet and
I agreed ahead of time that we would both
make videos about this hadith.
We didn’t confer on what we’d say in our
videos beyond the passage we’d be discussing,
so I have no idea what he’s going to say
in his video.
Let’s all click the link and find out what
AP’s got to say about his former prophet
lusting after some random woman.
I hope to see you there in the comments section.